about an hour before you're ready to
serve Christmas dinner it's time to cook
the final dishes and make the finishing
touches first I'm getting mom to help
cook my chili and turmeric roasted
potatoes
this dish is another twist on tradition
it gives the potatoes a lovely color and
their spicy kick helps complement a lift
the whole Christmas meal we're just
gonna do again a little twist the
potatoes region is new just for it oh no
no oh God
goose fat so we can do a really nice
lightly spiced roast potato okay little
chili flake okay
yeah Jenny if I just put away heat in
there well Christmas lunch yeah chief
Lake a little bit of turmeric I can't
believe you're doing your potatoes for
chili bro that's now would you be so
kind as to give them a little cuts cut
the peel potatoes into quarters and put
into salted cold water in they go okay
bring them up to the boil and simmer for
around eight minutes drain and let them
steam then season with salt and pepper
on that just a little teaspoon of chili
flake no that's the sort of thing I
would make for supper and a sudden I
hear someone a really chilly flakes in
add a teaspoon of turmeric turmeric is a
member of the ginger family it stains
the potatoes a wonderful golden color
and has a lovely earthy taste
next drizzling a little olive oil and
shake to coat them just let them all
round yeah that's nice beautiful could
you get me be they're stopping free from
the fridge put in a preheated baking
tray with extra olive oil and cook at
200 degrees Celsius for about 40 minutes
give a little shape to make sure they
don't stick and I'll just stick the
stuffing hang one on top here now now
we'll take roughly about the same time
as potato stuffing in shade is done nice
way to go play with the kids because I
worked long and unsociable house
throughout the year I really look
forward to catching up with friends and
family during the Christmas holidays
it's a time to be sociable parties
drinks guests dropping by and having a
warming jug of aromatic mulled wine and
some spiced nuts on hand really puts
everyone in the Christmas spirit
now that sound christmas is here mulled
wine is a real Christmas classic but I'm
going to give it a modern 21st century
twist first pour red wine into a pan and
gently heat now I'm gonna make a
fragrant bouquet garni basically a
really nice aromatic teabag muslin cloth
absolutely perfect for this Kevin got
muslin cloth a brand new Japheth is just
as good now first off cardamom pods they
incredib aromatic and more importantly
gives it a really nice dense spicy
flavor next add a pinch of clothes
clothes are dried flower buds and had a
lovely pungent sweet flavor then drop in
a couple of star anis which adds an
anise seed note a cinnamon stick
cinnamon sticks are made from the bark
of trees native to Sri Lanka break one
in and this gives a warm sweet spice to
the wine lemongrass this makes it
slightly Asian II a little bit more sort
of exciting but gives a really nice
light twist to the wine I want to do
first is just press down on the
lemongrass and what that does it starts
to release all that oil
and flavor once it's crushed just cut it
over the muslin cloth
once all your spices are in bother the
muslin cloth and tie tightly I know
then it's like a little mr. perfect
chest pillow into the wine next add
orange zest twist then cut the orange
into wedges and pop those in to
to sweeten the wine put in a tablespoon
of Demerara sugar
next stem ginger gives them all wire
little bit of a sort of kick almost like
that really nice sort of ginger beer
aftertaste on the back your throat
finally a couple of tablespoons of the
ginger syrup and then simply heat the
wine gently for four to five minutes to
infuse all the fantastic flavors but
don't let it boil or the alcohol will
evaporate and together that the most
amazing spice nuts I love nuts so I'm
using Brazil's almonds walnuts and
hazelnuts and then finally pistachios
lovely very nice festive mix as a nurse
toast they start to release their
natural oils then add a couple of
pinches of salt and then just let them
lightly toast once the nuts start to
color add half a teaspoon of cayenne
pepper which is made from ground chilies
then sprinkle in half a teaspoon of
paprika a milder spice made from dried
pimentos for sweetness and doubt
and now you can see the nuts absorbing
all that wonderful flavor some delicious
finally put in a sprig of rosemary give
the pan a good toss to make sure all the
nuts are thoroughly coated and they're
done
[Music]
my next chef secret is don't waste food
Christmas is a really expensive time but
with a little understanding of finesse
you can use up every edible part of your
Christmas shopping just like we do in my
restaurant kitchens otherwise it's money
down the drain
soups are one of the secrets in a chef's
Arsenal for delivering amazing flavor
whilst watching the pennies my next
recipe for sumptuous pumpkin soup uses
the whole pumpkin the leftover ham stock
and I'm getting the kids involved
toasting the pumpkin seeds as a snack
nothing goes to waste in my kitchen but
most importantly of all the soup tastes
absolutely delicious and with the
addition of sauteed wild mushrooms it's
fit to serve in my three mission star
restaurant right listen I need some help
I came to make the most amazing pumpkin
soup film hammy it's very heavy but it
is gonna be absolutely delicious right
they always tell okay if it's ripe go
with me on there
what does that sound like oh yeah drums
that's right okay push your thumb in
there should be just a little bit of
soft right at the bottom of the root
first of all we're cut it in half
very carefully just cut through I'm
using a French pumpkin but these
versatile vegetables come in all shapes
and sizes and colors at this time of
year they're nutty sweetness is ideal
for warming soups curries andros wait to
see what happens when we open this up
all right Holly that's for you now this
is where it's gonna get a little bit
gory okay you get your hands and you
scrape the seeds out resting rub them
together and just give a little clean
nice and gently good yeah
nice look at that good you mean yeah
come on Holly that's it
into the water now once the seeds are
out we're going to toast them in the
oven a little snack so this is a really
nice way I'm not wasting anything get
your fingers right in there Tilley there
you go whoo
once the pumpkin seeds are out score the
flesh to help it roast and absorb flavor
season and add a generous amount of
rosemary take the garlic rubbed on the
outside to perfuse the inside then add a
large glug of olive oil and as a garlic
roast with the rosemary it's sweet
almost buttery nutty taste will mellow
and flavor the pumpkin all the C's done
yeah almost good
after the pumpkin seeds have been
cleaned dry and season them ready for
the oven are they gonna roast in the
oven for about 45 to 50 minutes mother
good and waiting some other house at
about five minutes time tray please
Holly so beautiful sir alien right well
done big question have you wrapped
mummys present yet
let's go I'll give you a hand quickly
tell that garlic smells amazing
[Music]
holy chili
where's Hani he's going to a party
shield a party oh no any boys there oh I
don't know oh you're so diplomatic right
look they are now toasted do that
why haven't what taste one of those nice
yeah
but look at this wow that look amazing
and that is your roasted pumpkin now you
put the spoon down the size okay yeah
scooping out all that lovely roast
pumpkin we don't waste anything you know
skip ball into center roasting a pumpkin
intensifies the rich sweet flavor of its
flesh which is lovely for soups but also
great as a filling for ravioli or making
a delicious mash with butter nutmeg and
salt and pepper
that's the pumpkin done now I want you
to do is get these mushrooms here and
just peel them lengthwise okay onto the
plate again I'll get my onion chopped
olive all in okay nice and generous
dollop all because what this soup do
really nice and velvety onions in and
then scoop out a wonderful garlic has
been roasted on the pumpkin mmm lovely
so a bit of nutmeg on top of the onions
onions garlic nutmeg yeah and now a
pumpkin and you would come in handy
somewhere
this little baby it's for you
no you have perfect now I want you just
to grate some parmesan like that for me
okay
just I'm going to start roasting off the
parmesan as well so we get this really
nice rich
delicious pumpkin
chromosomes brilliant for enriching this
soup it's mellow care more flavor and
saltiness provide a lovely balance to
the sweet pumpkin now always to do let's
get all that in there okay
yeah good
[Music]
look at that now that roasted sort of
cheesy rosemary garlicky yeah olive oily
beautiful so far nothing's gone to waste
we'd use the whole pumpkin now I'm gonna
add the stock my hand was cooked in it
dis master doesn't it smells Christmassy
delicious oh that's just from cooking
our ham bring that up to the boil and
we'll let that cook out for 10 minutes
cream really important that was boarding
when the cream goes in okay you'll see
the color lightening that's going to a
really nice rich creamy taste okay now
we're going to so do the mushrooms it
would olive all in there yeah get nice
and hot we'll go first with the
pompadour more and you go good girl then
the getting it all in and then fine link
Chantelle nice lovely I'm going to put a
little bit of butter in there I forget
and they'll be ambassador nice I love
that the complex flavor of wild
mushrooms but we can't get them chestnut
or fill mushrooms still deliver great
taste
mushroom work really well with pumpkin
because they have a warm earthy flavor
that complements the pumpkin beautifully
so mushrooms into the center yeah from
there we got the parmesan just peel nice
long layers watch very carefully no just
sit on top by the parmesan helps to
season the mushroom and really give off
an amazing flavor okay we're going to
blend the soup and all we're going to do
is half fill the blender so the soup
gets really nicely aerated now there's a
bit of a naughty chef's trick a little
butter in there just in Tom so when it
blends it gets really nice and smooth
lid on on to the blender and we'll just
pulse it on and off first
nice Wow
and this is a moment we'll be waiting
for just one side of the bowl so that's
daddy's portion that this little bit
yours mmm now it'll taste blow gently
hmm
[Music]